so that is Courtney Cox's team daughter
Koko taking a selfie inside a bathroom
which got an interest interesting
response from her mama quote where are
you my daughter busted
Courtney relax don't worry Koko was at
her daddy David Arquette's house I love
that bob was on top of it Marin fine
little mother-daughter moment but
starting a family was not easy for
Courtney she shared with me the
heartbreak she endured trying to have
children you open about having multiple
miscarriages yourself I had a bunch of
miscarriages but I was really lucky to
have my little girl Coco who I had
through IVF most celebrities really do
keep their stuff private you know and
here you're putting it out on and then
never taught me that lesson I know
you're supposed to be private
I just don't think like that I feel very
blessed to have Coco and if I can share
any light or give her wisdom to somebody
or hope that of course I would share
anything I can and that ends I think
that's important Courtney is doing
exactly that in her intimate new
Facebook watch series nine months with
Courtney Cox in each episode of family
documents their own pregnancy
stories are filled with both joy and
pain a week after we found out she was
pregnant you deal with everything from
cancer to alcoholism whether you wanted
to get pregnant I mean it's just a lot
of different subjects it's been a busy
month for Courtney who has been helping
best friend jennifer aniston celebrate
her 50th birthday she wants everyone to
note their okay after their private jet
bound for Cabo was forced to make an
emergency landing this past week we were
just on a plane that was hit a pothole
and the tire I got some blew up blew off
blew up disintegrated honestly we're
very lucky landing with one tire missing
it's not as big a deal as it may sound
when you're on the plane you still went
and enjoy your weekend oh yeah
[Music]